I want to start today with some
genuinely good economic news and the
News itself is a very small data point
but there's a bigger story here and it's
the story first and foremost about how
is the economy doing right now that gets
us to what will the impact of the
economy be on the midterms
if people accurately understand the
state of the economy because it's about
the perception of the economy more than
the economy itself that affects how
people vote and then the bigger
conversation which I think continues to
be a very interesting one is what in
general can we say about the state of
the American economy when there's a
democrat in the White House versus when
there's a republican in the white house
so come along for the journey let's you
know rather than starting at thirty
thousand feet and getting down to the
runway excuse the analogy let's start at
the base and then get up to 30 000 feet
so economic news good news GDP has
accelerated in the United States at 2.6
percent in the third quarter we just got
these numbers remember the third quarter
uh is July August September and we get
those numbers at the end of the
following month which is now the end of
October expectation for GDP growth was
2.3 percent the actual number was 2.6 so
having an increase rather than a
decrease by standard economic metrics
where we want indefinite growth I know
uh it's good to have GDP growth and then
when it is better than the expectation
then it is considered even better and
indeed the stock market is reacting to
this uh quite favorably as of this
particular moment uh when we are filming
the Dow Jones Industrial Average is up
over 500 points and we will see where
the day finishes out a narrowing trade
deficit and increases in consumer
spending and government outlays boosted
the number all normal a sharp pullback
in housing subtracted from the number
part of a broader decline in private
investment consumer spending decelerated
increasing at just a 1.4 percent Pace in
the quarter down from two percent so
understand that oftentimes the reports
on this stuff are so unclear consumer
spending decelerated might make some
think that consumer spending is down it
is not it grew at a slightly lower rate
than in the previous quarter so the
obvious question when we get such
numbers is this must be terrible for
Democrats right how will Democrats and
Joe Biden ever survive this obviously
good news that's a joke one of my
followers on Twitter said something like
the way Fox News will report it is is
the economy doing better right now
because people expect Republicans to
take over in November so they are
spending now because they know the
economy will be better once republi it's
a joke but it wouldn't be completely
foreign to Fox News to pull something
like that so that's the GDP number let's
let's now take a look at the broader
economy we have an economy where we have
uh better than expected GDP growth
historically low unemployment to the
point where one could argue we are
within a few tenths of a point of what
we would consider full employment
Remember full employment isn't every
single person has a job
uh but by the economic definition of
Full Employment we're very close to that
uh consumer demand continues to grow
albeit at a slightly slower rate than it
did in the second quarter and there is
still high inflation of course there's
no there's no need to exclude that from
our analysis or to pretend that that's
not going on so it's becoming very
difficult to make the case that this is
a terrible economy but Republicans are
still doing it and that's what gets us
to the impact on the November election
there was a point
eight weeks ago ten weeks ago something
like that where the number of Americans
who said abortion access and the
overturning of Roe v Wade are top issues
in terms of the midterms
that has diminished and has been
supplanted by the economy which at the
end of the day in most elections it's
the economy that regularly rates as the
most important issue now sensible people
like many of you would say well David
the economy is doing well most economic
indicators are very good inflation's
high but everything else looks great
clearly on the strength of the economy
Democrats are going to do really well in
November right
not necessarily what matters is the
perception of the economy and by
straight up telling lies and focusing
only on inflation Republicans have
convinced many voters that we have a bad
economy right now
uh nearly full employment GDP growth
choppy but not crazy stock market but
many voters believe that there's
something very wrong with the economy
and if indeed they do believe that it
wouldn't be unexpected for them to vote
for Republicans since they are the out
party currently in terms of power in the
White House House and Senate this then
gets us to the last thing I want to
discuss a little bit which is in general
does the economy do better under
Democratic or republican presidents the
data are extraordinarily clear on this
don't trust me do your own research on
this but if you look historically
in the modern political era on average
the stock market does better under
democratic presidents job growth is
stronger under democratic presidents the
unemployment rate is lower under
democratic presidents GDP growth is
greater under democratic presidents
inflation is lower under democratic
presidents are there exceptions yes
um but that is an undeniable reality now
you will often hear talking points from
the right when uh confronted with this
undeniable data where they will say
things like well that's because a lot of
democratic presidents had the benefit of
a republican-controlled house to rein
them in
such statements have been evaluated
empirically and they are without Merit
sometimes you will hear well there's a
lag time so really like the first six
months of a democratic Administration
are the economic result of the previous
administration which might have been a
republic it's been studied
and there is no empirical evidence
suggesting that so don't take my word
for it unlike many others I don't tell
you that I hold the ultimate and unique
truth or a monopoly on the data or a
monopoly on evaluating the data do the
research yourself I've done it myself
I've made the spreadsheets myself and
I've looked at it closely
and unless I have lost every ability to
interpret even the most basic data
um this is the reality that I've
presented to you fact check me tell me
if you find something different this is
uh Beyond parody Donald Trump is having
such trouble doing like normal
interviews lately that he is
increasingly relegated to doing whack
job interviews the latest is with
conspiracy theorist Dinesh D'Souza and
it is quite frankly Beyond parody Dinesh
D'Souza is increasingly a darling of the
conspiracy right that believes Donald
Trump was actually the winner of the
2020 election Dinesh D'Souza made the
film 2000 mules this is a completely
farcical
obviously completely debunked film that
makes almost unfalsifiable claims based
on mobile phone geolocation data to
argue that because there were people
with mobile phones more or less near
ballot drop boxes at different times of
day during the early voting period in
2020 it is clear that they were caring
like mules remember that's the idea they
were mules for thousands or tens of
thousands of fraudulent ballots that
they were doing massive dumps with into
the drop boxes there's no evidence for
any of it widely debunked watch the film
if you want to blow two hours and then
uh research each of the claims and you
will find that it is vacant and vapid
but Trump loves it so Trump agreed to be
interviewed by Dinesh D'Souza and Donald
Trump's lies are getting more and more
sick and more and more disconnected from
reality if you can imagine that in this
first clip Donald Trump claims
some people voted 28 times on the Same
Day in 2020 this is a claim for which
there is no evidence there isn't a
little evidence
there isn't some of it there is no
evidence for this claim and Dinesh
D'Souza just nods along and then of
course they voted six seven eight times
here as much as they could in the local
area some of the people went back I
guess they said 28 times and one no one
day to vote at different places with you
know numerous votes but they can't they
can't put in a thousand because it
wouldn't be a pro you know wouldn't look
right right
you they voted 28 times
because voting a thousand times would
raise suspicions but voting 28 times was
fine under whose names
they never answer that question just the
most fundamental oh if I David Pacman
try to vote 28 times in 28 different
places at each place I have to give some
name and it has to be someone who hasn't
already voted but it's registered in
that particular Precinct how would I get
the names what names did I give
they don't tell us no the people voted
28 times they're very smart you know
they're going with five vote six vote
seven votes and then they go to another
one but it adds up to millions of votes
yeah absolutely delusional and again
it's the blind leading the blind Dinesh
D'Souza just nodding nodding nodding
nodding along in the next clip Donald
Trump raises the conspiracy theory that
William Barr his own attorney general
this is not you know Merrick Garland the
Trump's own Attorney General William
Barr covered up the election fraud
because of fear he had of Democrats it
was wonderful they didn't even do
checking Bill Barr was afraid to be
impeached he was petrified of being
impeached and look at Dinesh D'Souza not
along to something so completely absurd
when William Barr had almost no time
left
in this office at the time that he
refused to participate in the lies and
the delusions why would that be William
Barr's fear
in November December and January of 2020
and 2021 respectively the Democrats said
they were
going and all of a sudden we have a an
attorney general who is afraid to talk
about he's saying oh the election was
just wonderful and it wasn't
you know William Barr was in the uh
George H.W bush Administration much
earlier in his career he didn't seem
afraid of anybody or anything there and
then he had a lot of work that he did in
the private sector and you would think
if he had a time to be afraid of
Democrats when it might have damaged his
future Private Industry career it would
have been when he was working for George
H.W bush and he wasn't afraid then why
would he be afraid at the end of 2020
the start of 2021 near the end of his
career it just doesn't make any sense
whatsoever and then lastly Donald Trump
saying Fox News is not what it used to
be but listen carefully to the language
he uses talking about
it's much different than it was uh when
I first ran Fox I will tell you it's a
lot different talking about fox has
changed Fox is not doing for Trump when
he first ran and I know it says it
sounds like Trump is saying when I first
ran Fox what he means is when I first
ran Fox was different what Trump means
is what was ultimately a 100 percent
sycophant brown-nosing channel Fox News
is now only about 90 percent there
leaving themselves the escape hatch the
eject button in case Ron DeSantis or
someone else ultimately becomes the
nominee but that means you are on
Trump's naughty list you're no longer on
the nice list what a pathetic interview
and Trump reduced to being interviewed
by Dinesh D'Souza what a just totally
humiliating display and as usual as
usual
Trump only wants friendly interviews and
if it's anything but friendly sometimes
he'll hang up remember with NPR he'll
attack the interviewer the right way is
to ask Trump the questions tee up
softballs for him to knock out of the
park with lies and then just nod Dinesh
D'Souza really you know the right likes
to use the term NPC
Dinesh de Souza really playing the NPC
folks remember that our YouTube channel
is heading towards 2 million subscribers
this is an insane number for a little
old show like ours and the most
important piece of data I have for you
we have nearly three million existing
viewers who aren't subscribed and as
I've been talking about this more and
more of them email me and they say David
you know I watch you every day I checked
I'm not a subscriber I didn't need to
subscribe YouTube was already feeding me
all your videos very very important if
you were one of these we call them the
2.8ers there's about 2.8 million people
last month who watched our videos but
are not subscribed on YouTube you can
help us get to the 2 million subscriber
number like tomorrow if just you find
folks who watch but don't subscribe were
to hit that subscribe button we could be
there overnight youtube.com the David
packman show subscribe free it is free
and I will address this in the voicemail
segment today we'll take a quick quick
break and be right back
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
well another woman has come forward and
says Herschel Walker paid for one of my
abortions as well and the question we
have at this time is does this even
matter to the very same Republican
voters who say abortion is the most
important issue to them background on
this some weeks ago uh Georgia
Republican Senate candidate Herschel
Walker had a woman come forward and say
hey you know what he publicly says no
exceptions for abortion nothing nothing
nothing always against it because it's
murder but he urged me to get and paid
for an abortion for me some years ago
and then later when he got me pregnant
again he tried to get me to have another
abortion but that time I refused and he
is the father of one of my children this
was one woman Herschel Walker denied it
with very little credibility admitting
that yes he did send a check to the
woman but it was for the kid they had
together even though he sent the check
years before that kid was born
completely unbelievable any sensible
person looks at the facts and says
of course Herschel Walker paid for This
Woman's abortion it's very very clear
another woman has now come forward and
said Herschel Walker impregnated me and
also
urged me to get and paid for an abortion
that woman known currently as Jane Doe
is represented by attorney Gloria Allred
and uh let's listen to a little bit of
the press conference yesterday this is
again a second woman
Walker gave her cash to pay for the
abortion
and that she went to a clinic in Dallas
Texas
however while she was at the clinic
she became overwhelmed with emotion
she could not go through with it and she
left the clinic in tears
when Mr Walker called that night our
client told him what had happened and
that she had not gone through with the
abortion
he was upset
he pressured her to go back to the
clinic with him the next day to go
through with the abortion
the following day
Mr Walker drove her to the clinic
and waited in the parking lot for hours
until the abortion was completed and she
came out
then he drove her to the pharmacy
to pick up medications and supplies as
prescribed
and then he drove her home
in the days following the abortion Mr
Walker began to distance himself from
our client she was very distraught
because she felt that Mr Walker had
pressured her into having an abortion
she left Dallas after she moved out of
Dallas Mr Walker sent our client a note
apologizing for what he had put her
through
as you will hear from my client Jane Doe
she has come forward at this time
because she feels that it's important
that the truth comes out so you get the
sense and the picture of what's going on
here there is another moment at which
Gloria Allred presents what is alleged
to be a photo of Herschel Walker in the
bed of Jane Doe's hotel room this is a
photo
of Herschel Walker
our clients hotel room
on the bed
again this is Minnesota
okay and then we also heard by voice
from the woman herself talking about
what happened and making it clear that
she's a trump voter this is not
political for her
I am a registered independent
and I voted for Donald Trump in both
elections
I do not believe
that Herschel is morally fit
to be a U.S senator that's clear
and that is the reason why I am speaking
up
and providing proof so the question of
course is is this going to matter when
we look at the polling in this race it
is a dead Heat
half a point on average separates
Raphael Warnock the incumbent Democratic
senator and Herschel Walker
Walker is a liar
Walker is incompetent
Walker has no business being even in
this race but because of what has
happened to this country
because of what has happened to the
Georgia Republican electorate
Herschel Walker may be the next senator
from Georgia which is an incredible
incredible thing if you vote in Georgia
there are just days to go 12 days right
is that where we are let me see here
seven
and then yeah 12 days
with 12 days to go
we've got to do everything we can to
prevent a dangerously unqualified
individual from becoming the next
senator from Georgia let's go now to
Herschel Walker's reactions Herschel
Walker uh held some sort of a press
conference yesterday whenever he does
this it's a very very bad idea and
during this press conference he denies
yet another abortion claim remember a
second woman has come forward saying he
urged me to get an abortion he paid for
it I didn't want to do it after going to
the clinic he went back with me the next
day to make sure that I got that
abortion
um Herschel Walker denies it never
particularly credibly and then also says
he didn't kill JFK kind of making light
or making fun of the mere allegation
here as it is as if it would be
equivalent to accusing him of killing
JFK and you see in the background over
Walker's left shoulder if you're
watching that's Republican senator
Lindsey Graham we'll get to him and his
role in all of this in a moment Lindsay
just laughs at the entire thing
[Music]
and I also want to let you know I didn't
kill JFK
right now
Lindsay really liked that one I didn't
kill JFK either
Center one and he got crushed at that
debate now the Democrats are doing say
whatever they by the way Walker is
saying that he crushed Warnock at the
debate where Walker pulled out a fake
badge and the wind is the seat but I was
there to know they don't
they don't they don't know that uh I'm
from Riceville Georgia and I'm going to
win this seat I told him when I got in
this race I'm going to win it and they
now see that I am going to win it so I
just want you guys to know that this
right here that right now
I'm waiting to see
so I think that Senator why not saying
you're not like me too hot does it
this this of course has nothing to do
with Warnock this has to do with now
multiple women who accuse Herschel
Walker of the exact same thing
I remember the Kavanaugh storyline
really well yeah Lindsey Graham is
completely pathetic and again all of the
denials are really not very credible
here is one from Fox News yesterday
where Brett Bayer asks Herschel Walker
are you saying you don't even know the
person making the allegations and Walker
simply says it's a lie not a very strong
denial and remember this is how it
started with the first woman with the
first woman Walker was asked do you even
acknowledge knowing the woman and he
said I have no idea and then it was well
yes I do know the woman well yes uh I
did send her the money well yes I do
have a kid with a woman but I never
urged her to get an abortion so this is
this is his denial you tell me how
credible this is
all right well this was Gloria Allred
came forward with this client you're
saying you don't know this person
what I'm saying is this is a lot and
well that's a different question I've
said it once and I've moved on my
campaign he said it once about a
different woman moved on because we're
worried about what the Jordan people are
talking about yeah uh not particularly
convincing denials but then maybe the
wackiest part of this entire thing was
when Lindsey Graham got involved so I've
already played for you a clip of
Herschel Walker yesterday not very
convincingly denying a second allegation
of him urging a woman to get and
ultimately paying for her abortion you
saw Republican senator Lindsey Graham
just laughing in the background laughing
off the entire thing Lindsey Graham saw
this as a great opportunity
to go on Fox News and to do his I'm
angry routine this is the same routine
he did during the Brett Kavanaugh
confirmation hearings where he framed
Brett Kavanaugh as the biggest victim
maybe not only in the history of the
United States but maybe the history of
the world screaming and just acting
completely ridiculous he is now doing
the exact same thing he appeared
alongside Herschel Walker last night on
Fox News and he says the reason this is
all happening is because everybody is
scared to death about what a black
Republican senator might mean to other
black kids and there may be more
Republicans and it's just scary to
Democrats God they're scared to death of
Herschel Walker because if Herschel
Walker becomes a republican maybe every
other young child in America of color
might want to be a republican that's
what they're trying to do don't let them
get away with it team herschel.com I
want the biggest night for the Herschel
Walker campaign to be tonight right this
is a character that Lindsay has
developed I call it the faux indignation
where he is just absolutely furious at
grave injustices that don't actually
exist and that are only meant to prop up
bad candidates and the lies of others
and that is exactly what is happening
here Lindsey Graham is uh using this
to try to
justify that Democrats are the real
racists Democrats they only want black
people in power if they are on their
side when of course we actually know
it's the Republican party that has this
very long history of only allowing very
narrowly defined black folks to be part
of their movement uh Herschel Walker
fits the bill take a look at more of
this Lindsey Graham Insanity on Fox News
I Herschel they're beating all of our
Gods up but who is what is it about this
guy he changes the entire Narrative of
the lift we're a party of racist Sean
man you're a racist the Republican party
is racist well what happens when the
Republican Party elects and nominates
Herschel Walker an African-American
black Heisman Trophy winner right
Olympian it destroys the whole narrative
John James Tim Scott Herschel Walker
everybody in San Francisco is going to
jump off bridge
now the reality is Herschel Walker
winning first of all Herschel Walker
being nominated changes nothing about
The Narrative of the left and Herschel
Walker winning would change nothing
about The Narrative of the left
Republicans have for a long time
accepted and allowed very specific
minorities useful to them in very
particular ways to try to prove how not
racist they are and in fact they've done
it with Herschel Walker where Herschel
Walker has a platform that is simply
lies he doesn't know what he's talking
about on any political issue the big
issue for him was abortion where it was
absolutely pro-life abortion is murder
no exceptions no exceptions no
exceptions turns out he now has been
accused of urging multiple women and
paying for multiple women to get such
abortions and now when you criticize him
and you go Walker has no clue what he's
talking about he's a liar he's dishonest
and he's a hypocrite they come back and
go that's racist you're that's racist
you're being the racist because you're
saying this guy is a hypocrite and
incompetent no he's racist I'm sorry
he's incompetent and he is unqualified
and that's why we are saying it it has
nothing to do with his race
um he hasn't actually said by the way
even a single thing he would do for
black folks in Georgia nothing he's not
actually articulated a single policy
idea that he has to help black folks in
Georgia
um and then and at this point it's just
beyond belief
Lindsey Graham tries to interfere in the
Herschel Walker stuff by bringing up
Hunter Biden's laptop now you might be
saying well that's important because
Hunter Biden voters have to decide are
they're going to are they going to vote
for Hunter Biden for the position of
for the position of
um oh right Hunter Biden's not running
for anything don't say anything but as I
said earlier they mess with the wrong
Georgian right now well can I say
something yeah that's a hunter laptop
laptop it was supposed to be Russian
disinformation right before the election
it was true it got suppressed right
before the election have an anonymous
allegation from a lawyer in LA to try to
affect the outcome in a Georgia race
they tried to destroy a Kavanaugh
because they wanted the Supreme Court
see they're afraid of this man come into
the Senate because he would transform
the Republican Party we're not going to
let him get away with it I'm tired of it
it I'm tired of seeing people I know
yeah okay he's Furious We Get It Lindsay
uh by the way the only transformation
that Herschel Walker would do of the
Republican party is he would continue to
prove that there is no low there there
is no standard too low below which
Republican voters aren't willing to go
as long as it isn't a Democrat you could
be out there paying for abortions and
unable to explain your position on any
issue but as long as you're not Raphael
Warnock with a d next to your name there
is no standard below which these
Republican voters won't go absolutely
stunning stuff make sure you're
following us on Facebook facebook.com
davidpackman show we'll have all of
these clips there for your viewing
horror I guess I would say
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show today
we're going to be speaking with Chris
finan who's the executive director of
the National Coalition against
censorship and also author of the book
How Free Speech saved democracy uh Chris
really great having you on I appreciate
it well thanks I appreciate you having
me you know we've had conversations
about the first amendment that were very
legally oriented and we've had those
often with law professors and others one
of the interesting things about about
your book is that you delve more into
the history of when the suppression of
speech and the fight for free speech
were you contextualize it in history in
some interesting ways and one of the
things you point to just to start
somewhere and we could start anywhere
you talk about war as being one of the
big culprits used by governments to
suppress free speech and I think that
won't come as a huge shock to many in
our audience when we understand the idea
of for the purposes of supporting the
troops for National Security whatever
don't say this or say that that I think
will make sense but can you talk about
some of the examples of when war was
used in this way
sure because actually War World War one
was
um civil liberties meltdown in this
country and actually precipitated
lawyers for the first time to start
thinking about using the First Amendment
to protect uh speech that the government
might not agree with
um you know the the Sedition Act and
passed by Congress in
um at the behest of President Wilson
actually provided prison sentences about
the 10 years for people who spoke out
against the war and it was ultimately
used to prosecute over 2 000 Americans
some for the most inane kinds of
criticisms like Wilson is a blockhead
or people who circulated petitions
um you know the most today what we would
say is the most
frequent forms of speech were suppressed
and uh and people were sent to jail over
a thousand people were sent to jail many
lives were ruined
um and it was against that background
that um that the ACLU was formed in 1920
and um
and began to fight and of course you
know in subsequent Wars we would see
um similar efforts at suppression
certainly during the Vietnam war
uh what modern Administration and we can
include the Vietnam War era in that I
mean you know in the last 80 or so years
was most harmful I guess is the word I
would use when it comes to suppression
of speech is the is there a clear
Administration I guess
well yeah Wilson clearly stands out
because
there was so uh there was so little law
actually on the First Amendment before
the 20th century and and there had been
a whole Century before and go you know
go all the way back to the Alien and
Sedition actually right at the turn of
the the 18th century into the 19th
um newspaper editors were thrown into
jail for criticizing the administration
of John Adams
um and um
so
um so there was but there was very
little law on uh First Amendment rights
before
um you know before World War one so and
then you know the um there were
certainly efforts during the the Nixon
Administration around the Pentagon
papers efforts to suppress right
um you know that very critical study of
the Vietnam War
um you know Daniel Ellsberg was actually
indicted for sharing that with the New
York Times And The Washington Post and
um and might well have gone to jail if
um the Supreme Court hadn't stepped in
and said that
um that that was protected speech are
you surprised or I guess what do you
make of how the American right wing
recently has very proactively claimed
Free Speech as one of its core tenets
despite sort of not only having a shaky
history on the subject in the past but
even while claiming uh that as one of
its tenants you know talking about Trump
wants to jail flag burners or open up
libel laws which basically is code for
make it easier to sue newspapers and
media outlets for doing journalism uh is
it is it surprising historically that
you would see that uh seeming uh
conflict and what else do you sort of
think about that
well it's wildly ironic yeah it's wildly
ironic to hear conservatives
um uh advocating as Defenders of free
speech when over the course of American
History they have been the the major
violators of uh of of that freedom
because they've often you know been in
the majority and the people who have
been advocating for free speech have
been people fighting for equal rights
and that was something that you know
they opposed and
um you know this goes back to the
um it goes back
to the abolitionists and to the women's
women's rights activists and activists
for sexual Freedom
um you know they you know they have
um at every at every turn conservatives
have tried to suppress uh suppress their
speech and right through the civil
rights movement of course and into the
into the modern era and as you say
Donald Trump was a big
um
uh you know wave the big stick against
the Press called the press the enemy of
the people
um uh so yes to suddenly see
conservatives advocating you know for
free speech rights is um ironic and also
typical for us because it alienates our
kind of our traditional base which is
young people and liberals and
progressives who have been part of those
equal rights fights there are many
accusations hurled at the left about
suppressing speech including uh
different types of alleged censorship on
college campuses both when it comes to
alleged lack of political diversity
among faculty but also as it pertains to
invited speakers to college campuses has
become a very big kind of Flashpoint to
some degree along the lines of LGBT
discussions most recently when it comes
to trans rights the right will sometimes
hurl allegations at the left what do you
think is the biggest area of concern on
the left when it comes to stifling free
speech
well I think you know I think and that
again is you know a change in the
political climate
um around free speech
but
um
you know I think that it's
understandable
um in a world that's suffused now with
misinformation and hate speech that
um that people progressives
sometimes tried to suppress speech
themselves and we are concerned about
those efforts on campus and we are
concerned about we certainly support the
right to protest speakers on campus and
to
um and to present the other view but we
really think it's it's a mistake to try
to suppress them because they then
conservatives just turn around and point
to that as justification for the the
suppression that they wanted right yeah
my view on this has been you know an
unsavory guest is invited to a campus
someone I'm not interested in seeing
fine
um
if they have been properly invited and
there's no criminal issue and whatever
else certainly inter there's nothing
wrong with the invitation and the fact
that they have an event protesting
outside the event absolutely fine with
it the protesters shouldn't be
restricted to some pen a block and a
half away where nobody sees that be
absolutely fine once the event starts it
does seem to me that it's correct to
allow the speaker to speak and then you
can continue expressing your displeasure
during a q a for example the
Counterpoint will be well there might be
no q a so your only opportunity is while
the speaker is speaking or
um I understand that it starts to get to
one of these things of well you know the
protests can't only be the way
everybody's comfortable part of
protesting historically is sometimes the
protests happen in a way and at a time
and in a place where it is an imposition
on some one else but fundamentally I I
do think that preventing the speaker
from speaking is a mistake
yeah and I think it also applies to
trying to revoke invitations that have
been made to speakers if there are
people on campus who want to hear that
speaker they should have the right to to
hear them but by the same token that
those who don't have an absolute right
to to protest and
um but we don't want to you know we
don't want to say Free Speech only for
our side which is really what the
conservatives are saying it's it is free
speech for us
um and and not for you because then that
lays the groundwork for what we are
seeing now around the country which is
these hundreds hundreds of
challenges to books in schools and
libraries the progressives care deeply
about there these are books about race
and the Persistence of racism in America
and how to look at slavery and
um uh and the and the lives of LGBT
people and you know their right to be
represented in school libraries and
um and so you know we can't we have to
protect this is the classic statement we
have to protect the rights of all in
order to uh ensure that everybody has
rights when it comes to the book Banning
you know the the the truth is I have
researched it is that the right is
overwhelmingly the side that has the
lists of books that should not be in
libraries but very often the right will
hurl back at the left look at what
happened with Dr Seuss they canceled Dr
Seuss Etc to me it does not seem
analogous for a publisher to decide
we're not going to continue new editions
of certain books because some of the
imagery or messaging is outdated based
on current Norms that's very different
than here's a list of 20 books that
shouldn't even be available in the
library from your perspective are these
two very different things or are they
equivalent the way the right States
no I I don't think they're equivalent I
I think that um and they're and the
cases are very slim you know the the
cases that they can point to of
alleged suppression of books certainly
um just don't hold up the the
overwhelming majority of challenges to
books in schools are coming from coming
from conservatives and um and parents
who just don't want their kids or
anybody else's kids to have access to
books that in many cases are are
life-saving because they
they show LGBT kids that they belong
that they are accepted
um and these are you know these are very
important books and also how we present
our history
last thing I want to ask you about
um what do you make of the tie between
actual issues of suppression of speech
by governments and some of the sort of
cancel culture social media Private
Business discussion that now is going on
certainly legally I think at this point
most of us although some people call me
and they don't seem to get this
difference most of us understand that
legally uh Twitter can have terms of
service wherein they don't allow certain
types of statements to be made it's not
a First Amendment issue it has nothing
to do with that that we understand so we
can sort of skip beyond that but
ideologically
and from a principal's standpoint when
there is not a legal issue what would an
organization like yours say about some
of the terms of service on these social
media platforms that do limit the things
that are allowed
well we understand
um the power of social media and um and
we understand you know why the decisions
that get made on social media are so
um uh are so important to people we have
we have an Arts advocacy project
ourselves to you know try and push back
against algorithms that are banning all
nudity for example including artistic
nudity from from social media
um
uh but ultimately you know we hold with
the view that that the companies have to
be allowed as as is their First
Amendment right to make decisions about
you know what content they allow and and
don't allow and
um uh you know and and unfortunately at
this point you know there are efforts
underway there are laws that have
recently been passed in Texas and
Florida that are trying to force uh
social media companies to accept content
that they don't want right and that you
know that is a step toward government
you know government intervention in uh
free speech that we just can't we can't
allow it we have to challenge yeah
that's an important point it's
ultimately government intervention
either way uh and that's that's a
critical point we've been speaking with
Chris feinen who's the executive
director of the National Coalition
against censorship the book is How Free
Speech saved democracy which we will
link to from our uh YouTube clip for
this interview Chris really appreciate
your time today
thanks for having me
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
so tomorrow or or probably next week I
will have a report for you about the
legal challenges that are already
starting for the midterm elections that
are 12 days away yeah they're doing it
again there's no question that they're
doing it again we've already seen a
number of legal challenge challenges
start and if you want to sort of get a
jump on that story you can Google it and
you'll find some examples Fox News
propaganda Tucker Carlson is doing
something very dangerous and I fear and
I believe that the fear is a very
rational and sober fear I fear that they
are going to be doing 2020 all over
again where they are priming the right
wing and the pro-trump people are
priming their audiences and their voters
to believe if we lose
it must have been fraud
and they are priming them to be angry to
the point where they may again become
violent here's a clip from last night's
Tucker Carlson propaganda show on Fox
News
where he is in an overtly dangerous way
starting to say listen some of these
people if they supposedly win they
definitely didn't and you should be
ready for that then he brings on Glenn
griftwald to talk about it which we
won't be looking at it keeps working
it's not about the person it's about the
party it's not about the individual it's
about the group
and to prove it they can even run
mentally defective candidates you can
barely speak now by the way when he says
mentally defective candidates who can
barely speak
we know he's talking about John
fetterman but fetterman's not barely de
fact mentally defective fetterman had a
stroke and as an auditory processing
issue and it's abundantly clear when you
see fetterman right
that he can absolutely uh uh make the
case as his doctors have that he has his
mental faculties in place
Tucker should be talking about Herschel
Walker but he's not
but he's talking about fetterman okay
let's continue with the video I'll go
back a moment immensely defective
candidates you can barely speak and not
only expect them to win but expect you
to accept the outcome no matter how
transparently absurd it is
on November 9th they'll be telling you
that John fetterman got 81 million votes
in Pennsylvania and they'll threaten to
put you in jail if you don't believe it
why wouldn't they do that it worked with
Joe Biden
Glenn Greenwald is an independent
journalist his work is on substation yes
sub stack okay so candidates that can
barely speak he should be talking about
Herschel Walker he's talking about John
Federman Tucker just makes things up and
the line that he is implicitly going
with here is elections we lose are
rigged that's the name of the game and
this the groundwork was laid in 2019
into 2020. they tried it in 2020
they may have got been able to get away
with it in some localized instances
which fortunately they did not but they
got close enough to stealing some
electoral votes that of course they're
going to try it again and the name of
the game now is
if we lose it was rigged and if we win
we say nothing at all look at what was
happening in the Arizona gubernatorial
race where it was a close race carry
Lake ultimately won
when it looked like Kerry Lake was down
by a little bit
she and others immediately started with
the voter fraud claims irregularities
here early voting problem there mail-in
ballot problem here and on and on and on
and then she ended up winning by a
little bit and they basically shut their
mouths about the fraud if you ask them
they do have a ready-made explanation
and the ready-made explanation is well
there was tons of Fraud and attempts to
rig it we just won by so much that even
with the fraud we ended up winning by a
little bit
that's their explanation and of course
it is unfalsifiable we are soon going to
be putting out a really good white paper
guide sort of thing it'll be free to
everybody in our audience of how to
approach people when they make claims
like this how can you start and and kind
of have a conversation where you agree
on
what is it we're trying to figure out
and how do we determine what is the
truth and one of the things that that
guide is going to include is a sort of
um uh not a warning a sort of notice
that when the standard is one that
depends on you to falsify something
that's not falsifiable
it's not even really worth getting
involved and what I mean by that is
the voter fraud election fraud it was
rigged people they can always say you
haven't definitively proven to me that
there was no rigging and of course if
there is no rigging it's hard to prove
definitively that there was no rigging
because there's an absence of evidence
for rigging that's it burden of proof
has been shifted and so it's really
important to consider is the standard of
proof that someone else is putting out
an impossible standard to me because I
can go to them and say okay
um the number of registered voters and
submitted ballots perfectly aligns with
the state's population age demographics
for how many registered voters there
could be historical turnout that all
looks fine
the uh anecdotal reports of specific
fraud double voting dead voters Etc
we've run them down and found that they
are without Merit so we have no reason
to believe that there was election fraud
here and they'll say you have not proven
to me what about that claim and that
claim and that claim an increasingly
unbelievable claims so it's very
important at some point to be able to
understand the burden of proof you were
claiming something that is not supported
by the by the data and is an
extraordinary claim that all of the
results we have reflect the wrong winner
per the will of the people you have to
prove it at some point the burden of
proof has to be on them and
unfortunately when Tucker just goes
listen they're going to make you accept
that candidates who can't speak got a
ton of votes it's just it just doesn't
work he is priming these folks
dangerously to reject losses as fraud
and it could it's we know it can get
very ugly look at 2020 okay lawyers
losing their licenses violence death
okay we know it can get very ugly and it
may again get very ugly if Florida is at
the center of a republican Civil War
that I absolutely love
Florida Republican Governor Ron DeSantis
is almost certainly going to win
re-election it's just what the polls say
and everybody should get out there and
vote for Charlie Crist but in all
likelihood the winner is going to be Ron
DeSantis Donald Trump has announced a
series of rallies including in Florida
in support of 2022 candidates he is
doing a rally in Florida with Marco
Rubio who's running for re-election to
the Senate but Ron DeSantis is
conspicuously excluded from that we know
what this is all about my friends this
is a snub because Trump is furious with
DeSantis DeSantis when asked has not
ruled out running in 2024 for the
Republican Presidential nomination even
if even if Donald Trump wants the
nomination as well Donald Trump expects
unending loyalty from other Republicans
what Trump wants the scientists to have
said is
I won't challenge Donald Trump this
nomination is trumps if he wants it if
he doesn't then I'll think about my
political future DeSantis hasn't done
that and why hasn't DeSantis done it
well if you look at the betting markets
you see that DeSantis is essentially
running tied with Donald Trump when you
ask people who do you believe will be
the Republican nominee that these aren't
polls in the polls Trump is still doing
much better these are betting markets
DeSantis and Trump have been right neck
and neck for a couple of months at this
point in time DeSantis knows he is
positioned to maybe be the Republican
Presidential nominee which would be a
big Boon for him without a doubt and
this is making Trump Furious uh
political reports Trump to hold rally in
Florida with Rubio but not DeSantis
the apparent snub or angered some people
within DeSantis orbit who complained
that the Florida Governor's team was not
informed of the rally prior it is
abundantly clear what is going on here
Donald Trump correctly and accurately
sees Ron DeSantis as a threat to Trump's
potential desire to be the Republican
nominee in 2024 and so this Civil War is
growing and growing and growing I've
told you before the numerous reports of
Donald Trump privately fuming at Ron
DeSantis and increasingly we have seen
Ron DeSantis publicly distance himself
from Donald Trump when it comes to
Florida's coveted response and other
things this is a great thing this is a
great thing the more Strife there is
from now because listen 2024 starts in
12 days after the November midterm the
more Strife there is between these folks
leading up to the primary I believe the
more they will weaken each other and
hopefully hurt themselves in the event
eventual general election of 2024 we
will have plenty of time to discuss that
but you really love to see it we have a
voicemail number that number is 2192
David P listen this this really bums me
out
I have been accurately telling you fine
folks in my audience you can subscribe
for free to my YouTube channel it's just
it's YouTube okay you just subscribe
that just means you get our videos it's
free it's completely free you can
subscribe free to our podcast it's on
iTunes Spotify Pandora Stitcher it's
everywhere it's free okay
and
every once in a while I get a voicemail
like this and it really bums me out
hello
Craig going to your site you say on T on
your
uh podcast that I can subscribe for free
and there's nowhere to subscribe for
free what kind of scam are you pulling
yeah there is no scam
95 of the content we do
on every platform is free to everyone we
have a YouTube channel youtube.com the
davidpackman show
it's YouTube guys it's free you can
subscribe free
we have a podcast an hour every single
weekday
it's free you go to our website you go
to iTunes you go whatever is your
favorite podcasting app it's free
what we charge for
website memberships which come with a
commercial free version of the show
they come with access to the bonus show
oh the bonus show where you want to make
money yeah everybody else that makes
money to fund themselves is bad and they
come with other perks okay but it's free
to subscribe on YouTube it's free to
subscribe to the podcast there's no scam
here there's no scam here let's all
relax we have a great bonus show for you
today Joe Biden is going after so-called
junk fees I will tell you what these are
Texas is going permitless on guns
that'll go well right and three men have
been convicted on all counts for the
plot to kidnap
Michigan Democratic governor Gretchen
Whitmer remember that story they have
all been convicted on all counts all of
those stories and more on today's bonus
show sign up with peace and love at
joinpakman.com this isn't free okay this
part's not free you can use the coupon
code big voting22 to get a discount but
if you want to request a free membership
we have some to give away you can
request a free membership at
davidpackman.com
slash free membership we'll see you on
the bonus show